- If, there were like, fire
alarm starts goin' off,
then you're like, "What?"
You'd be like,
Oh, no!
(woosh)
(slow jazz music)
- Today, I'm gonna be trying
a portable steam sauna.
Don't know exactly what that means,
but I know I'm probably
gonna get really sweaty.
- I feel like you guys are gonna put me
in a makeshift spa castle.
Kind of little, like, Amazon Prime thing.
- I like saunas, I like anything hot;
hot tubs, saunas, I love them all.
- I love saunas, I love, like,
sweating with a bunch of half-naked dudes.
America's greatest pastime!
(keyboard typing)
(curious music)
- Wow!
(laughing)
- It looks like a robot costume.
(hysterical laughing)
- If there are too many steps,
then it's gonna be bad for me.
- This feels like I'm
building my kid's crib.
- So, next, we need (click)
- These directions are
not easy to understand.
- This looks promising.
- 'Cause they're calling these, like,
side tubes and back tubes, but, like,
why don't they call it
curved tube with no connectors on the end?
- Do you break this down
and build it up every
time you want to use it?
'Cause, like, maybe
you just get in the car
and drive to a sauna.
(rustling)
- Alright.
Yo!
- Sometimes, you just gotta
give it a little pelvic thrust,
you know?
Then, it works.
Look at that.
- Come on, baby.
Come on, baby.
- And I'm already so sweaty.
- Bam.
Bam!
(Sighing) Turning it on...
(clock ticking)
- I want to relax, but this
is just making me stressed.
- I'm just gonna do it
this way, I don't...
(rustling)
I'm in it. I'm in.
(gasp)
I think the pill box is
something you wanna avoid.
- I wanna go in and take
off my pants, though.
'Cause I don't wanna get
my pants all soaked, so.
'Scuse me, guys.
- Jesus Christ.
(coughing)
- Turtle, turtle!
Turtle, turtle!
I'm going in to my shell!
- I feel like these aren't my hands;
these are someone else's hands.
You know, like, feeding me food.
- Don't tell my girlfriend I
got naked at work, alright?
- Damn, it gets hot.
It does really get hot in here.
- I feel like I just got
transported to the beach.
- See all that sweat?
Look at it, it's working!
See that?
I'm glistenin'!
- I'm here, guys.
I survived; it was
wonderful and beautiful.
- Oh, wow!
My body temperature is cooled down.
My legs aren't as glisten-y,
and my sweat smells very good.
- If I was going to like
a bachelorette party,
I would definitely consider bringing it,
'cause, you know, it just
seems like bachelorette parties
doing relaxation, pedis, and stuff.
And then it's like,
"Oh, you guys are doing
pedis? What about a sauna?"
And all the girls would be like, "Yeah!"
- If I had a change of clothes,
I definitely would have
stayed in there forever.
Hands down.
It was good.
'Bout to cancel on your literal baths.
I don't know.
Maybe I could do some drugs
and go on a spirit journey, in here?
I don't really know.
(relaxed jazz music)
(woosh)
(squeak)